Yellowstone National Park an underground
supervolcano is drawing visitors hoping
for a different kind of eruption a
geyser that you that is usually dormant
has shot off over and over again
Jamie yuccas shows us how volcanic
activity under the park is producing a
spectacular water show Yellowstone is as
beautiful as it is unpredictable
more than three thousand square miles of
hot springs mud volcanoes and of course
geysers Old Faithful may be the park's
most famous but steamboat is now
grabbing the spotlight as the world's
largest active geyser we see gas
emissions we see all kinds of thermal
activity that's what Yellowstone does
it's one of the most dynamic places on
earth steamboat has erupted ten times in
three months prior to that it erupted
just 10 times in 27 years but
volcanologists like Wendy Stovall don't
know why there's now so much activity at
Steamboat I think when people start
hearing that you know steamboat geysers
going off in the back of their mind they
think oh my gosh what if the big one
happen right there's been a lot of hype
about the supervolcano of Yellowstone
and the potential for a super eruption
because this geyser field at Yellowstone
National Park lies on top of an active
volcano with multiple chambers of magma
from deep beneath the earth an explosion
means lava flows could cover several
states the explosion was sent ash clouds
as far as Chicago Seattle and Los
Angeles the good news the last one
happened 70,000 years ago there's no
evidence that we can say from all of the
monitoring equipment that we have that
there will be a super eruption anytime
soon but that doesn't stop volcanologist
from collecting data on the yellowstone
plumbing system a 50 mile wide magma
field scientists also monitor 28
seismograph stations throughout the park
because a supervolcano would include
major earthquake activity so far nothing
indicates danger if people are worried
about that happening in their lifetimes
I think they may be focused on the wrong
sorts of things that
why steamboats calling card these days
isn't gloom and doom it's the chance to
see something spectacular eruptions are
ice fun parents yeah so Bella and Brock
Duclos are starting daughter Villette
early bringing the one-year-old to see
steamboat even with mom eight months
pregnant
it could go 300 feet in the air that's
so that would be amazing so even without
a super volcanic blast there's a super
interest in science this is amazing this
is a nerds paradise is like your Super
Bowl yes yes it's so much better for CBS
this morning Jamie yuccas Yellowstone